the nfl has an ongoing battle with
vontez berfick there will be an appeal
of that 12-game suspension and i suspect
devontes berfit will get it trimmed down
to maybe six games eight games maybe if
he's lucky he'll get it down to four
games
here's what derek carr the raiders
quarterback had to say about
vontez berfit
burfict is one of the most misunderstood
people in the nfl he's a great guy i
don't think the suspension is fair his
heart is broken
i don't think there's anything
misunderstood about vontez perfect and i
know look teammates got to support a
teammate but i think this is a situation
where your best play is to say nothing
that's a matter between vontez perfect
and the league we have to focus on who's
available to play we hope he wins his
appeal we hope to have him back but
don't call him misunderstood nobody's
misunderstanding vontae's perfect he's a
dirty player and he always was chris
yeah i mean mike i i mean with you you
know it's okay to defend the guy and go
hey you know this guy's like better in
the locker room than people realize he's
been a great teammate that way
yes misunderstood no he's not we
completely understand that he's one of
the dirtiest players we've ever seen
there's nothing to misunderstand about
that so that's wrong and oakland raiders
you've lost your like uh ability to talk
on these subjects sorry you told me
antonio brown was misunderstood too no
no we understand he's a douche okay
sorry don't know other way to say that
either so stop like defending like this
stupid crap like i just i don't get that
it kind of frustrates me as you as you
can tell but um yeah there's nothing
misunderstood about what vanta's perfect
has been on the football field
and you know this is an example of
another quarterback who just doesn't get
it just because you can throw a football
doesn't mean you are a leader because
there's got to be guys in that locker
room who are wondering when derek carr
says this he's really he's misunderstood
like we've played on teams that have had
to deal with vontez perfect he's not
misunderstood now if he's on your team
you love him if he's not on your team
you hate him yeah but there's no
misunderstanding at this point the guy's
got a long list of infractions and it's
finally caught up to him and the nfl has
taken a strong stand and again i think
he'll be somewhat successful on his
appeal but you know he already left
london he knows he's not going to get
the entire suspension thrown out right
the question is how many games will it
get and when and when is antonio brown's
misunderstood vontez burfex
misunderstood and who are we waiting for
next to the trifecta of the
misunderstood
who is it yeah you know i mean i feel
like it's only a matter of time before
something happens with richie incognito
and then we start to say there you go
richie incognito is misunderstood right
yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports